welcome to Table Talk my name is Brett
and the pastor at the table where our
mission is to shift a generation from
reactionary to visionary to the person
and work of Jesus this is episode number
1 of my show and I want to talk about
the framework you need to understand
spiritual growth so there was something
very real and certain Christians
I knew something I saw in them that I
wanted in me but it was hard to name
exactly what it was it was a sort of
quiet confidence
everyone would be freaking out and they
would just sit there everyone would be
speaking yeah they would be quiet
they seemed happier than most almost
like faith had gone deep in them like
they were connected to God in some way
that many others weren't it was what
allowed them to be upfront leading or in
the back serving they could preach the
sermon or watch the babies and kids
ministry all I knew was to call it
spiritual maturity they were really good
disciples of Jesus but again I sort of
lacked the language to know what it was
or how to grow into it myself and then a
few years back I came across the
writings of a Christian monk named
Thomas Merton
and he gave me some incredibly helpful
language around this he wrote all sins
starts from the assumption that my false
self the self that exists only in my own
egocentric desires is the fundamental
reality of life to which everything else
in the universe is ordered he continued
thus I use up my life in the desire for
pleasures and the thirsts for
experiences for power honor knowledge
love to clothe this false self and
construct its nothingness into something
objectively real in other words Merton
is naming that there is this part of me
this grasping craving part of me this
restless never content never at peace
part of me that we might call my false
self I believe this is what the Apostle
Paul in Romans 8 verse 5 calls the flesh
when he writes these words that those
who live according to the flesh have
their minds set on what the flesh
desires so on the one hand we have this
flesh or this false self but on the
other hand we have what Paul calls
spirit or what Merton would call the
true soul the true self is that part of
me that I encounter in silence it's that
deep part of me that's always already
connected to God it's that part of me
that I experiencing when I'm suddenly
overwhelmed by peace joy by love and
compassion by patience by kindness it's
that part of me that is deeply content
and longs to not simply believe in Jesus
but to actually live like Jesus so there
you have it the flesh versus the spirit
the false self versus the true self so
coming back to where I began what was it
I was saying in these Christians that I
so admired it was that they had learned
to live more and more from their true
self and not their false self and when I
think of who Christ was he suddenly
makes so much sense because he was
someone who lived perfectly from his
true self that's why he could say I
don't say anything except what I hear
the father saying I don't do anything
except when I see the father doing Jesus
lived perfectly from his true self and
so this is my obsession helping
Christians learn to live from their true
selves how do we do that in a thousand
different ways through prayer and
fasting and journaling counseling
listening you know confession and on and
on in fact in many ways this is the
journey I'm on and that I would
share with all of you in the content I'm
putting out each day because if if we
could move just a dozen or a hundred or
a thousand people in that direction
beginning with myself I think that could
make all the difference in the world but
that's all for today if you like this
video please like and share it and
subscribe to my youtube channel so you
don't miss future videos grace and peace